taystee in the front and just like Bam
Bam Bam punching with your dick on the
way out
I think I can handle spicy food the only
thing is I get the hiccups when I eat
spicy food so I don't take spicy food
too well
I'm not intimidated by spicy food that's
a cute dog when I was a child my grandma
used to spike my food with spice to make
sure I could handle it
oh this is a challenge oh this smells
good so
oh my god okay oh boy yeah I feel it but
it's not that bad it's definitely a
painful spice rather than a flavorful
spice oh my god I'm such a white person
oh I get the hiccups every time I eat oh
I guess every time I poop see I just
pick up
huh for her it's definitely getting
worse I mean it's good - the pain then
boom
I'm a bad person to get to these like I
put so much [ __ ] in my body I have a
whole bunch on my face so my face is
burning look at my fingers I think my
tongue grew two sizes I'm not Korean but
I'm Asian so it's like you know I think
my grandma won against everyone she's
like oh you're sad that I spiked your
food with spice we'll listen I lived
through two revolutions [ __ ]